today the matt welsh show blm is back to
rioting back to their old tricks again
this time over the shooting of an armed
man
who was charging at police officers with
a weapon blm
is going off script i think by rioting
only a week before the election we'll
see how that
factors in um hopefully voters will take
notice and we'll talk about that also
five headlines including amy coney
barrett's
confirmation plus tampax tries to earn
some woke points by marketing itself to
men
who have periods which is a category
that doesn't exist
and in our daily cancellation i will
cancel pets i've already canceled all
humans
so pets are next it's only fair all of
that coming up but first
a word from ready wise listen you never
know what might happen in the future
and that's why you have to be prepared
just in case now is a
better time than any to be prepared with
long-term nutritional food options ready
wise
fortunately has has many options uh like
emergency meals
freeze dried fruits and vegetables for
convenient on the go nutrition and my
favorite
new adventure meals for hiking camping
other outdoor activities ready wise
makes being prepared simple and
affordable also delicious the food is
great you can order online have
nutritious
meals shipped directly to your doorstep
but here's something to keep in mind
due to increased demand supplies are
limited and some items may not currently
be in stock so you have to order now
don't wait
and so this you got to pay attention to
this part especially
this week my listeners can get free
shipping at readywise.com
when entering wall check out or by
calling 855-475-3089 readywise is a
90-day
90-day no questions asked return policy
so there's no risk taking the initiative
to get yourself
and your family prepared today that's
readywise r-e-a-d-y-w-i-s-e
dot com promo code walsh to get free
shipping okay well
there were as the media calls it clashes
between
protesters and police in philadelphia
last night what this really means of
course is that rioters and looters
wreaked wanton destruction across the
city and assaulted police officers at
will that's what the clashes
just to show you what a clash between
police officers and rioters looks like a
quote-unquote clash
here's a whole group of police officers
running away and retreating
as rioters chased after them while
hurling projectiles this happened last
night in philly watch
oh
[Applause]
that's what i like
[Laughter]
now call that what you like just don't
call it a clash
by the end of the night at least 30 cops
had been hurt and at least one officer
was in the hospital with serious
injuries
a female sergeant 56 years old was was
hit and suffered a
broken leg when a truck plowed into a
group of officers uh the the group that
she was standing in
elsewhere riders set cop cars and fire
ransacked stores looted police vehicles
here's a quick clip of some of these
warriors for racial justice
stealing from a local business owner in
order to bring about equality
or something here's here's what that
looked like
[Music]
oh okay
now the ostensible reason for this
latest bit
of barbarity is the shooting of 27 year
old walter wallace jr
um i'll tell you what i'll show you that
shooting first and then we'll we'll talk
about it before we go any further though
here's here's the that video
yo watch yo watch the world don't shoot
the wheel
yo this crazy
crazy
[Applause]
oh my god oh my god oh they just killed
them in front of me
now as you can see wallace was armed
with a knife
police instructed him to drop the weapon
and surrender
rather than complying wallace approached
them while brandishing the weapon it's
all there on video you can see it for
yourself
at that point they opened fire this is
about as justified as a police shooting
can possibly get
so in order to get around this leftists
are playing their usual game
of turning the focus away from the
relevant facts of the incident
and towards personal details that are
not at all relevant to the shooting
itself
philadelphia inquirer reporter ellie
rushing for example
tells us that wallace was quote a twin a
father and a son
and that his mother quote begged police
not to shoot
but the fact that wallace has a child
and a twin brother has
absolutely no bearing on whether the
shooting is justified
activists are also telling us that
wallace was shot in front of his mother
and that wallace
allegedly had a mental illness again
none of this makes the shooting
unjustified whatever his family
situation whatever his psychological
condition
all that matters in that moment is that
he's armed with a deadly weapon
and charging at the officers if somebody
was coming at you with a knife
i doubt you would stop to ask him if he
has a child or a twin brother
or to see his most recent psych
evaluation i don't think you would
police have the right to protect
themselves from an assailant
who could cause them grave harm and who
seems intent on doing so
all of the facts about wallace's life
and family make it sadder that he chose
to throw his life away by
charging at cops with a knife but they
don't change the fact
that the cops had the right to protect
themselves and the duty to protect the
community from a dangerous assailant
which is what they did
but notice something if you haven't
already what's happened here is that blm
and its allies have completely dropped
the
unarmed black man line now it used to be
if you remember a few years ago
that blm would cherry pick only the
shootings of allegedly
unarmed black men to protest which of
course often meant ignoring the fact
that unarmed people can still pose a
lethal threat to police officers
as the michael brown case definitively
showed but but now
and beginning earlier this summer the
suspect's possession of a weapon is
simply ignored
even if he's brandishing a weapon and
appears intent on using it
still this is treated as irrelevant
remember
unarmed used to be nearly the entire
reason for the protest at least the
entire reason that was given they'd say
they shot an unarmed black man that was
the cry right
now it's just they shot a black man
as if there could simply never be a
legitimate reason to shoot a black man
the very fact that he's black means that
the shooting is racist
no matter the circumstance this is this
is the position of blm i'm not
exaggerating as you know
it's worth reflecting though on the
incredible amount of racism
involved here because blm is so
desperate to find a reason to riot
that they'll riot when when armed black
suspects are shot while
charging at police officers they have
not found enough
unarmed black suspects being killed by
cops to satisfy their lust for
destruction so now they're relying on
these sorts of
incidents but they could retain an ounce
of credibility
and perhaps keep up appearances of
caring about police brutality
and still find dozens of opportunities
to riot every year
if they expanded the scope of their
outrage to include to include
unarmed white suspects killed by cops
these are after all there are after all
more of those
in a given year yet they refuse to
protest the killing of white people
they would rather protest the killing of
an armed black man charging at cops
that an unarmed white man like daniel
shaver shot while on his knees begging
for his life
this is just an unfathomable
unfathomable degree of racism
racism nihilism destruction hate lies
propaganda that's what blm is all about
which is why it's found such a staunch
ally the democrat party because they are
kindred spirits in so many ways
and that's something to think about now
only one week out from the election
you know i had frequently fretted on
this show that the american public
with the intentions with the attention
span of and memory of
a housefly might forget about the riots
when they go to the polls
given that most of the rioting petered
out a few weeks ago right but
blm has helpfully given the public a
reminder
and done so in a crucial swing state we
might add a state that trump needs to
win
in order to stay in the white house and
now they're rioting in that state
uh uh only a week out from the election
i i can tell you something if if biden
loses
you know we're hearing a lot about
hunter biden right now well we're
hearing a lot depending on what media
you choose to listen to
if you listen to mainstream media not
hear much about it but
uh the hunter biden scandal is a big
scandal but
i think if if biden loses it's going to
have a lot more to do with
what happened in philly last night and
things like that
than it will hunter biden because people
look at
hunter biden and they say to themselves
i'm not really sure how this affects my
life i don't think it does
uh people rioting in your city though
burning down buildings destroying
businesses
assaulting killing people yeah that
affects you that really affects you
it's easy to make that connection of
course the corruption
of of of of a president
as joe biden and his family all evidence
points to them being very corrupt
corruption does affect you but it's
harder to connect those dots in your
mind
yet when you look outside your window
and see these rioting mobs yeah
not hard to connect those dots so blm
as i said going off script writing a
week out from the election
i just hope that people remember that
and keep that in mind
uh because for all the flaws of the
republican party the fact is there is
one party that openly advocates and
supports
destruction and rioting and that is a
democrat party it's as simple as that
let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know it's extremely important to
hedge your investments with some gold
but the problem is it's
also extremely expensive to just go out
and buy buy gold and it seems like a
rather daunting thing to do
well here's something new you know how
the price of gold has been skyrocketing
lately
now there's a new way to buy gold
through a company called
acre acre is a great company i'll
explain it to you they let you subscribe
to gold bars for as little as 30
a month you pay each month and once your
gold stash
reaches the price of their gold bars
they discreetly ship
acre gold to your house so it that's
it's pretty simple that's how it works
acre lets you invest in physical gold
without coming out of pocket all at once
acre keeps you updated on your gold
statue every month
uh they ship you uh your your gold stash
once you reach the price
threshold with acre taking physical
delivery of your gold means it's safe
uh and it's it's a it's a really easy
way to get that
gold shipped to you and get it in your
hands acre ships your gold directly and
discreetly to your door
acre designs their gold in california
and sources their gold from one of the
largest mints in switzerland
uh you know i i personally would would
love to have gold but i know for me too
it's it's an expensive thing to just go
out and buy so acre's a solution for all
of us visit
getacregold.com walsh and start
investing in physical gold today
make sure you go to uh this your url
because acres giving away a gold bar
they're giving one away
to qualify for the giveaway tweet or
post why you should be the recipient and
mention
at get underscore acre again that's get
acre gold dot com slash walsh make sure
you tweet at them tell them why you need
it come up with a really good
good creative reason and maybe you'll
get your own gold bar
thank you uh to acre gold for supporting
the show remember get acre gold dot com
slash walsh all right we um
as i i am currently in nashville and
i'll have more about that
about the journey here in a little bit
but uh this is just just so you know
this is not my new national studio
uh this is the studio's still being
built so
i am in our rental home and we we also
don't have a house here yet so we're
renting and then we're gonna
buy a house uh as we you know get to
know the area a little bit more
so i'm uh in just a a corner of our
rental house
and the our four kids are like stashed
somewhere else in the house and this is
what's happening
and a little a little look into the
behind the scenes here i had a nice
setup
like ready to go in this house and i
thought this is gonna look nice
and then right before i went to start
shooting the show
uh someone outside started mowing the
lawn and it was too loud so i had to i
had to relocate
these are these are the challenges when
you do what i do for a living
really difficult obstacles to overcome
but we all have we all have those in our
lives don't we
all right let's go uh number one amy
coney barrett was officially sworn in
as a supreme court justice last night
sworn in by clarence thomas
a great moment wonderful sight to behold
and if you're a red-blooded american
patriotic american it was a wonderful
sight and if you value the constitution
it was a wonderful sight let's uh let's
watch it again here it is
i am solemnly swearing
that i will support and defend the
constitution
of the united states that i will support
and defend
the constitution of the united states
against
all enemies foreign and domestic against
all
enemies foreign and domestic that i will
bear
true faith and allegiance to the same
that i will bear true faith and
allegiance to the same
that i take this obligation freely that
i take this obligation freely
without any mental reservation without
any mental reservation
or purpose of evasion or purpose of
evasion
and that i will well and faithfully
discharge
the duties of the office from which i'm
about to end
the duties of the office on which i am
about to enter
so help me god so help me god
so of course the left reacted to this as
expected
they desperately tried to find some
reason to be
outraged that the white house and the
senate had lawfully discharged its
constitutional power and responsibility
to nominate and confirm supreme court
justice
they've been trying this whole time to
find some reason to conjure up some
reason to be outraged by this
and they haven't really been able to
figure it out um they haven't really
been able to explain
why it's a problem they've gone through
different different
versions they've had different talking
points oh remember ruth bader ginsburg's
last wish her dying wish it defies that
like that didn't really work so they
went to something else
uh they're not really sure why they
don't like it or why it's wrong
they just know it is wrong because it
makes their tummies hurt and i would
respect them a lot more if they would
just come out and say that
if nancy pelosi or someone would just
come out and say listen we just don't it
makes our tummy certain we don't like it
okay i respect that i don't really
respect it but i appreciate the honesty
so instead they're trying to find some
other
thing that uh republicans have allegedly
done wrong here
uh and of course one of them is that
this defies
a precedent that was set
four years ago allegedly this uh
confirming any amy coney barrett is in
defiance of
a four-year-old precedent
and so in order to show how much they
care about presidents
and how much they value presidents they
are now advocating that we also destroy
a 150 year old president by expanding
the supreme court supreme court's had
nine uh justices on it
for you know starting in the same decade
as the civil war
and they want to get rid of that
precedent because they care about
precedent so much
in fact aoc tweeted last night um she
said expand the court and then she also
said
republicans do this because they don't
believe dems have the stones to play
hardball
have the stones well that seems like
misogynistic
gender stereotypical language doesn't it
that seems like toxic masculinity have
the stones
i don't know about that aoc i think i'm
offended by that anyway
don't believe dems have the stones to
play hardball like they do
and for a long time they've been correct
but do not let them
bully the public into thinking their
bulldozing is normal but a response
isn't
there is a legal process for expansion
yeah legal well there's a legal process
for just nominating a justice
and confirming them when there's a
vacancy on the there's also a legal
process for that
republicans follow the legal process
they did absolutely nothing illegal here
but reading into that you know a couple
of things jump out at me
first of all i think we might need to
expand if we could
expand aoc's iq to get it into like
triple digits
then maybe we wouldn't have to read
tweets like this
because really of all the inane nonsense
that streams from the mouths of democrat
shills like
like this woman the idea that
republicans
always play hardball while democrats
meekly sit in the corner
and just comply that has to be the most
inane of all
but you hear this from democrats a lot
this thing
uh republicans are always they've got
they're the ones with the backbone that
are there that are the re
i wish that was true i wish it was
it's not um but the strangest reaction
had to come from chuck schumer
i think listen to what he had to say
about uh the confirmation
here at this late hour
at the end of this sordid chapter in the
history of the senate
the history of the supreme court my
deepest and greatest sadness
is for the american people generations
yet unborn
will suffer the consequences of this
nomination
as the globe gets warmer as workers
continue to fall behind
as unlimited dark money floods our
politics
as reactionary state legislatures
curtail a woman's right to choose
gerrymander districts and limit the
rights of minorities to vote
my deepest greatest and most abiding
sadness tonight
is for the american people and what this
nomination
will mean for their lives
their freedoms their fundamental rights
monday october 26
2020 it will go down
as one of the darkest days in the 231
year history
of the united states senate i yield the
floor so you'll see again there chuck
schumer trying to conjure up some kind
of
righteous indignation over this totally
normal thing that's just happened
but he says generations yet unborn will
suffer the consequences of this
nomination he really said that
i i i have to believe that when
democrats say stuff like this
that they they are knowingly trolling
so yes yes uh generations on board will
suffer the consequences
they will suffer the consequences of
being allowed to be born
that's the consequence they can be born
now whereas otherwise they wouldn't be
as if roe v wade is actually overturned
which
uh by the way i don't think it really
will be but i hope it is but i doubt it
anyway that's that's the consequence
he's worried about that future
generations are allowed to be born
and i suppose according to the
anti-natalist
anti-life democrats that really is a
terrible consequence
so there's a certain logic to it i
suppose
number two this is uh also not supposed
to be funny
or ironic as far as i know but i found
it hilarious a new lincoln project ad
which is supposed to show us the grisly
future that awaits us
should trump retain uh power
and anyway here's the ad listen to
[Music]
and where the this were headed where we
were trending
ohio florida
hey honey
[Music]
you asked me to wake you and tell you
what happened in the election
who won
trump trump won
but i thought you could only be
president two times
[Applause]
not anymore
[Music]
right so i wanted to show you that
because along with being hysterically
funny it also
perfectly encapsulates the perhaps fatal
mistake
the left has made in dealing with with
donald trump
if they lose i think this will also be a
part of the reason why they lose
because they decided to oppose
trump by pretending he's a terrifying
fascist dictator
right and the thing is when you're
running against a politician or where
you're when you're in opposition to a
politician
um you have to have a simple
narrative about him
you're trying to brand him you're trying
to get the public to see
him in a certain way and uh it can't be
too it certainly can't be contradictory
and it can't be too complicated it has
to be simple
and with trump you'd think you know
there are various different directions
you could go with that
but they went and there are a few
like brands that you could probably make
stick
on donald trump they chose the one that
will not stick and hasn't stuck which is
that trump is this terrifying fascist
dictator
they want to they want us to see him as
an intimidating
scary sort of character but he's donald
trump for god's sake
it just it doesn't work who really sees
him that way
nobody except for the most radical
fringe lunatic leftist who maybe maybe
sincerely does
all the rest of us we see him as donald
trump
and love him or hate him anyone who's
been conscious for the past four years
can clearly see
that the guy's about as far from a
dictator as you can get
he is easily the least dictatorial
president
we have had in generations easily
it's not there's not even a contest here
he doesn't even control his own white
house
he's got people that are directly under
him who are undermining him
investigating him going to the uh to the
to the press constantly
do you think that happens with a
dictator
he doesn't even control the people who
he's supposed to be able to control
and then covet came along and the
complaint from people like the folks
in lincoln project and all the other
leftists is that he
didn't exploit the opportunity to seize
more power
they're upset that he allegedly didn't
do enough now i don't really think
that's true but that's
their argument okay but a dictator
would have taken advantage of this
opportunity to seize
way more power i mean a dictator that's
worth assault
is given something like this a pandemic
they're going to exploit that to the max
to consolidate their own power and trump
could have done that and he didn't
and the same people accusing him of
being a dictator are in this case upset
that he wasn't dictatorial enough so it
just it doesn't make any sense
um and uh and it it doesn't work i think
what the what they could have tried to
do instead
is try to just make trump into a joke
into sort of like a clown like they did
with george bush
uh that was that was their their
their method and their approach with
george bush
and uh even though he won reelection of
course he was elected to two terms but
it was
it was largely successful with trump
though now there's
they still do some of that
but they're kind of contradicting
themselves i mean either he's this joke
that we shouldn't take seriously
or he's this terrifying fascist dictator
he can't really be both
uh or at least it's difficult to make
both of those things stick
and so instead neither have really stuck
okay um and by the way this is this is a
criticism that i had of trump about
for a while about biden and i said the
trump campaign was not doing enough to
define
biden to put a brand on biden like
how should we see biden and um and
i i think they've gotten better about
that recently and now biden is
you know uh largely a a
uh uh just bumbling stumbling
you know man who's losing his
his mental acuity which also happens to
be correct but i think that's how people
see him
and uh if he loses it's going to be
largely because they seem that way all
right number three from the daily wire
a memo sent by delta airline ceo ed
bastian
alert employees that 460 people have
been added to the no-fly list for
refusing to comply with mask mandates
from the airline the no-fly list is
typically reserved for suspected
terrorists
but now they've got a no-fly list for
people who don't wear masks
so you're terrorists if you don't wear a
mask speaking of which
um when we got into nashville we we
decided to walk
downtown to the most touristy part of
downtown just to check it out
and here's what you see if you go down
there this is what you're greeted
with if you visit the city as a tourist
you're going to see this big sign here
mask on or stay home and this by the way
directed at people walking down the
street not just people going into the
bars if you're walking down the street
you're supposed to wear it
and they're going to find you allegedly
if you don't now we didn't wear the mask
we didn't get fined
but um but still this is you you see
this everywhere although i will say
credit to tennessee from what i've seen
of it so far you know obviously i've
only been here for a few days but
uh what you see down in like downtown
nashville is different from if you get
out
into greater nashville if you go if you
certainly when we were driving across
the state
um we saw actually very few people
wearing masks which
which was nice okay number four
over the weekend biden speaking of being
a man losing his mind
seemed to indicate that he believes that
he is running against george bush this
is what he said listen
this is the most consequent not because
i'm running but because who i'm running
against it's the most consequential
election
uh in a long long long time
and the character of the country in my
view is literally on the ballot
what kind of country we're going to be
four more years of george
georgia he uh gonna find ourselves in a
position where
if uh trump gets elected uh we're gonna
be uh we're gonna be in a different
world
you can see the woman doing the sign
language for him there i feel bad for
biden's sign language interpreters i'd
never thought about that
until seeing that video but what do you
do if you're a sign language interpreter
for joe biden
what the hell you sp how do you convert
his ramblings
into coherent signing that seems
difficult
but anyway biden says four more years of
george
pretty clear though that's what he said
and he makes a few attempts
um but but is not able to conjure up
donald trump's full name this is not a
normal flub right this is not a normal
thing unless you have dementia than it
is
[Music]
but to confuse donald trump with george
bush
of course the media as biden's rapid
response team was ready to swoop in and
do their jobs
uh do their jobs to to cover for their
man and right on cue jake tapper brian
stelter other usual suspects came
came up with a cover story their cover
story was uh oh no no this is all fake
news
he didn't confuse george bush with
donald trump uh
joe biden was was talking to george
lopez in that interview and so that
explains why he said george
this is this is what they're going with
and he was talking to george lopez for
some reason but
that doesn't explain why he said four
more years of
george so now you're telling us that he
thought
he's running against george lopez and
that there might be four more years of
george lopez you think that
that makes it better in your mind that
makes him that makes him seem more with
it
you would say no i don't think so either
way i mean he confused donald trump and
some george i i guess picture george we
can't really say he didn't say bush in
fairness
he confused donald trump with some other
george curious george who knows
um but matter no matter which george he
confused them with i think it's uh
it's not a good sign number five
tampax the tampon brand tweeted this
recently uh this is what they tweeted as
fact
not all women have periods also a fact
not all people with periods are women
let's celebrate the diversity of all
people who bleed
myth busting hashtag period truths
hashtag
trans is beautiful right
of course you know you know the first
question i'm going to ask when i read
that is uh
what is a woman if not all people who
menstruate are women
then please give us a workable
definition of woman you can't
i i see that by now okay so moving past
that second point
celebrating people who bleed seems like
the lowest imaginable bar
right yes we all bleed that doesn't mean
we all
menstruate though and third point think
about what tampax is doing here
they're embarrassing themselves pissing
off a majority of their customer base
um in order to pander to a tiny
infantessimal fraction
of their customers how many
percentage-wise
how many of their customers do you think
are people who would call themselves men
either women who identify as men and are
buying tampons
or even men who identify as women and
for some reason are buying tampons
of those two categories like put them
together
what percentage of the overall customer
base is that for tampax or even of the
potential overall customer base
i don't think it's even close to one
percent
and so what what's in it for them you
think about from 10 packs of perspective
what's in it for you to send a tweet
like this
it's not like you were gonna lose
customers by not tweeting it i don't
think there were very many people
who were who were you know tampax
customers and were about to stop buying
tampax because tampax had yet to come
out
and give their opinion about whether or
not men can have periods i don't think
anyone was worried about that
so by bringing this up as a brand you
can only lose
customers you can't win this is this is
a this is a no-win situation
you're taking off a lot of people who
would not have been ticked off otherwise
and you're impressing a very small
minority of people
who even them most of them probably
would have been ticked off if you hadn't
said anything at all
so what's in it for you really nothing
but this is this speaks to the left's
cultural dominance
that big corporations are willing to
lose money
just to signal their allegiance to
leftism
that is the true hallmark of cultural
dominance
but but remember of course that leftism
is still somehow counterculture
corporations are losing money just to
bow to leftism
yet leftists still position themselves
as the counterculture
radicals somehow right sure
not very convincing let's get to our
daily cancellation in just one second
but before we do you know the
presidential election is almost here and
we have an amazing day of programming
for you our live stream starts on
tuesday november 3rd at 3 pm eastern 12
p.m pacific featuring special guests
live interviews and more
leading up to a very special episode of
backstage where we will be covering the
results with you in real time and even
better
you can join daily wire right now get 25
off with code election elections
you can watch all of our election
coverage live on our apple tv or roku
app
members get our articles ad free access
to our live broadcast and show library
the full three hours of ben shapiro show
you get all of that uh you know all the
the perks that come with being an all
access member
and you can watch the election with us
at dailywire.com get 25
off your daily wire membership with code
election when you sign up today
okay time for our daily cancellation
today we are cancelling
pets all domesticated non-productive
non-human house dwelling species are
canceled
if you have one in your home right now
you can break the news to them however
you like
but they're cancelled and i don't say
this based solely on my own anecdotal
experience but my anecdotal experience
is nonetheless instructive i think
especially after having traveled many
hundreds of miles with a pet
once again to move once again uh we have
lugged
my wife's cat not my cat my wife's cat
hither and yawn house after house
for no discernible reason we just cart
this thing around
and she doesn't make it easy for us so
the worst was when we we moved back to
uh the baltimore area from our brief
two-year stint in kentucky
this is about five years ago or so and
we um we tried to drive it all in one
day
two kids babies at the time plus the cat
and we were making the long trek across
west virginia driving basically the
whole length of the state it was getting
late the weather was bad it was december
you know up in the mountains so we
decided we had that we had to stop and
sleep for the night it was the safest
thing to do
the problem is that we had the dumb cat
and we became
like the holy family in bethlehem
wandering around looking for an inn that
would take us in
but they kept telling us no cats some
would accept dogs
but not cats literal racism but that's
that's a cancellation for another day
finally i said enough of this and we
chose a hotel
i didn't ask about the cat instead i
just tried to sneak her into the hotel
i did and i got one of those luggage
carts i put the cat carrier on the car
covered it in a like a jacket and
luggage then i tried to sneak it in
but right as i was getting on the
elevator and and trying to uh you know
close the door
the front desk woman ran over to me and
said sir sir excuse me
do you do you have a cat
and quickly my mind ran through a number
of possible responses including ditching
the cat in the elevator making a run for
it moving to mexico changing my name
living my life as a fugitive i figured
my wife might be a little miffed if i
chose that option
though so instead i said yeah i do i do
have a cat
i do this is the cat right here you
caught me and there was another brief
moment of us standing there
staring at each other before the woman
had to break the news to me that she was
kicking our asses out
i had to collect my family and the
luggage make the walk of shame back out
the building
past the front desk the most humiliating
moment of my life
and i've had many of them by the way
humiliating moments i mean not lives
only cats have multiple lives because
being utterly useless in one life isn't
enough it seems
finally we found this dumpy old motel uh
the kind where you know the person at
the front desk is behind bulletproof
glass
and there was a drug bust currently
happening in a room downstairs i'm not
making that up that really happened
so i walked in and um and i i said to
the guy i said
can i bring my cat in and the guy looked
at me as if to say
you can shoot heroin here of course you
can bring in a cat
so i was grateful but then we got to the
room and it was well you know it was
what you'd imagine
bugs all over the bathroom strange
smells a door that didn't shut properly
a severed human foot in the closet you
know that sort of thing the kind of
motel room
where you only end up if things have
gone horribly wrong in your life
as they had for ours for us in that
moment anyway
so my wife breaks down in tears so she
can't stay here she's scared for the
baby she's scared that we'll be murdered
in the middle of the night
i explained there's probably only like a
10 chance of that happening
if that but she was hardly consoled so
eventually we decided to leave the cat
in the motel room
she didn't mind the bugs the cat okay
she liked the bugs actually
so we we left her there we went and
checked into a regular hotel
came back the next day to pick up the
cat found her down in the lobby
continental breakfast eating a stale
muffin that part isn't
technically true but we did actually
give our cat her own motel room and came
back to pick her up the next day
the housekeeper was confused is all i
can say
this last trip to tennessee wasn't as
bad that's because i spent
hours calling around trying to find
hotels ahead of time that would accept
cats
after about three hours i couldn't find
one then my wife went on her phone
found one in five minutes whatever she
won't let me live that down probably for
another
couple of years so the hotel wasn't a
big issue but the cat did puke
pee and poop in her carrier like 10
minutes into the drive
just evacuated all of her exits all at
once and the car still smells like a
petting zoo five days later
but here's the question this is why i
bring all this up
what was all of this for why are we
going through this
why am i dealing with this puking
pooping
creature especially when i have kids who
do quite enough of
all of that already what are we getting
out of the bargain
the cat has never lifted a finger to
help around the house the most she'll do
is kill a mouse or a snake and leave its
rotting carcass on my porch
and you might say oh she's trying to
share food with you okay well even if
she is
she always eats the meatiest part of it
herself and leaves the bones and skin
for the rest of us selfish bastard
frankly
as are all pets i mean we have a box in
our house
like any cat owner where she relieves
herself
just a box of cat poop sitting there in
the basement
and i have to debase myself by going and
extracting her droppings and throwing
them away
i'm like five steps above her on the
food chain but she has subjugated me
somehow and this is a cat we're talking
about
dogs are far worse so don't think oh
yeah cats dogs are better no
dogs are far neater far more emotionally
unstable
people say they love having a dog who's
always happy to see them when they get
home
but do you really need that much
affirmation that aggressively
every day you need someone to literally
lick your face and slobber all over you
as soon as you walk in the door
every day do you ever get to the point
where you say dude
just relax bro okay give me some
personal space
how would you react if a human did the
equivalent of that every time you came
home
like as soon as you walk in the door
your spouse runs up to you and screams
you're home thank god you're home i
missed you so much
i'm so happy that you're home wouldn't
that get old after about two and a half
seconds
or maybe it wouldn't for you maybe you'd
enjoy that you narcissist
but the weird thing about a narcissistic
dog owner is you still see them walking
down the street holding bags of their
dog's feces
so they're narcissistic but also they
have no sense of self-worth
this is what has become of our species
and you know these are the same people
who they'll see a video of some
allegedly cute
uh dog doing something on you know some
allegedly cute dog video online
and they'll say we don't deserve dogs
dogs are angels
sent from heaven we don't deserve them
what we don't deserve
them we do everything for them they do
nothing for us
no they don't deserve us no pets do to
include your gerbil
your bird your pet iguana so i'm
cancelling all of them
even your goldfish is canceled enough is
enough
someone has to stand up to that little
bully and that's what i'm doing right
now
besides like i said i already canceled
all humans
it's only fair to throw pets into the
equation as well
so nobody's allowed to have pets anymore
uh i think we'll be a lot better off for
it
and i i think as americans we spend like
five billion dollars a year or something
on our pets
don't quote me on that but it's in the
billions so we'd save a lot of money too
so in the end i'm saving you money you
should thank me for that but your pets
are canceled
and that does it for us today thanks for
watching thanks for listening
godspeed
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
hey everyone it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show
amy coney barrett has become the first
smoking hot supreme court justice
and our leftist tears tumblers are
magically overflowing
it isn't right for us to spend an entire
show just drinking leftist tears to the
dregs
but they taste so good join me on the
andrew clavin show